welcome to the Stars Halloween night our
couples are ready for a night of tricks
treats intense competition the
competition was devilishly fierce
tonight as the stars brought their most
wicked routines to the ballroom
but for Lori Hernandez and Val
Chmerkovskiy things started off on a bit
of an emotional note is my creativity
good enough it's crazy how fast life
moves a mortgage she brings the joy in
everything
I just don't want to blow it for her you
know the pair's Willy Wonka themed
Viennese Waltz completely dazzled the
judges earning them yet again another
perfect score as for James Hinchcliffe
he danced with Jenna Johnson after his
partner Sharna Burgess sustained an
injury last week I spoke to my doctor
I'm supposed to have three to six weeks
off I'm sorry in costume as the Joker
and Harley Quinn they're Viennese Waltz
also got straight tens agendize want to
go there and do her proud oh they
absolutely crushed it I it was so good
that in a really weird twisted way I got
emotional in the skybox afterwards
because I was watching you like
everybody else I wasn't in it I was
watching you live and I was blown away
Reiner so how are you doing because I
know everybody on social media was
wondering I think I'll be out of dance
next week I have another assessment on
Friday make sure that I am all good but
this is a competition and another couple
was sent packing
the couple leaving right now is Ryan and
Cheryl I definitely feel proud that I
made it this far I never thought in a
million years I would make it to week
eight we were just really happy to be
here I think the one thing I really
learned is no matter how hard I get
knocked down I can keep fighting keep
getting back up and staying positive
you